[Music]
hi guys it's quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the youtube algorithm
really notices me
just a heads up this video will have
spoilers for all three of chichen liu's
remembrance of earth's past books and
also for the spin-off novel redemption
of time by bashu
this series details the story of mankind
after they discover that there is a race
of alien beings four light years away
from our solar system that seek to
destroy humanity and inhabit the earth
it will take about 400 years for the
aliens to reach earth but in the
meantime they have crippled
technological progress on earth so that
humans could not advance enough to match
them
humanity was nearly fully destroyed in
the struggle against this
technologically superior alien race
the great war between humanity and the
tricelerians drives the main narrative
of this series and yet we never see the
appearance of the tricelerans described
in the original trilogy
it's not until the spin-off that we
finally get a glimpse at what they
actually look like
however we do receive information in the
first book about their biology and their
life cycle
tricelerians had much longer life spans
than humans and could live for hundreds
of years or between 700 and 800 thousand
tricelerian hours
but it is mentioned that most
tricelerians will lose the ability to
work productively long before that
period of time
once this happens those tricelerin
individuals would be dehydrated forcibly
and burned
if tricelerians could not work they were
not considered of use to their
civilization
the tricelerians also have the ability
to fully dehydrate themselves and exist
in an unconscious state indefinitely
only to be rehydrated at a later time
this was the adaptation which had
allowed them to be able to survive the
harsh conditions of their three-star
solar system
their planet existed in a constant state
of varying extremes which came about
suddenly
some errors were stable but there was no
way to tell how long stable errors would
last or to predict when stable errors
would occur
this is the three-body problem which the
title of the book refers to
the tricelerians spent eons attempting
to solve the three-body problem but
eventually realized that there was no
solution
they needed a new star system
we know that the tricelerians do not
have the ability to lie this is because
their thoughts are displayed openly
instantly readable to other tricelerians
this is why they never developed the
capacity for deception
lying was impossible when your thoughts
were not private
tricelerian mating was also vastly
different from humans
when two tricelerians made it organic
material from both bodies became one
approximately 66 percent of the material
would be used to power the biochemical
reaction which would renew the cells and
create a new body
this new body would then divide into
between three and five new individuals
who would each inherit some of their
parents memories and go on to begin the
cycle again the leader of the
tricelarens is referred to by the title
of princeps essentially the princeps
fills the role that a king or emperor
would fill on earth only on a global
scale
because of the nature of their existence
and the instability of their planet
their culture developed to value only
survival
some tricelerian individuals however saw
the faults in their civilization such as
the listener the lowly triceleran who
first heard the call of earth and
betrayed his species by warning us not
to respond to their message when
explaining to the princess why he had
betrayed his own world he told them that
it was so his own life would not be
wasted
he was too old and too low of status to
mate and try solaris offered nothing to
those on the lower echelons of their
civilization
but by warning earth he could give
humanity a chance to survive listener
compared trisolaris desire to possess
living space to the desire of a man who
has gone too long without food
he knew that they could not coexist with
the humans on earth he knew that they
would be destroyed the princess
questions how listener would be the
savior of earth while his own people
would perish and he responds by saying
this
i am tired of try solaris
we have nothing in our lives and spirit
except the fight for survival
what is wrong with that
there is nothing wrong of course
existence is the premise for everything
else but princess please examine our
lives
everything is devoted to survival to
permit the survival of the civilization
as a whole there is almost no respect
for the individual
someone who can no longer work is put to
death tricelerian society exists under a
state of extreme authoritarianism the
law has only two outcomes the guilty are
put to death
and the not guilty are released
for me the most intolerable aspects are
the spiritual monotony and desiccation
anything that can lead to spiritual
weakness is declared evil
we have no literature no art no pursuit
of beauty and enjoyment we cannot even
speak of love
princess
is there meaning to such a life
the kind of civilization you yearn for
once existed on trisolaris ii
they had free democratic societies and
they left behind rich cultural legacies
you know barely anything about them most
details have been sealed away and
forbidden from view but in all the
cycles of tricelerian civilization this
type of civilization was the weakest and
most short-lived
a modest chaotic era disaster was enough
to extinguish them
look again at the earth civilization you
wish to save a society born and bred in
the eternal spring of a beautiful hot
house would not be able to survive even
a million tricelerian hours if it were
transplanted here
surviving and existing are very
different from living and thriving the
culture of trisolaris was characterized
by a lack of culture
they existed only to serve the hierarchy
individuals did not matter only the
system mattered what's really
interesting about this is both
triceleris and earth have a traitor
amongst their species humanity's traitor
was of course yawinji and trisolaris's
was the listener
both individuals can no longer see the
good in their own worlds and would
rather help another at the expense of
their own
now let's talk about the spin-off novel
redemption of time
now though this book is approved by
shush and lu some do not consider it to
be official canon redemption of time
describes the tricelerians as small
creatures no larger than a grain of rice
this is the explanation for why the
trisolarens would have never risked
direct combat with humans who could
easily crush them
tian ming whose brain had been captured
and his body rebuilt by the tricelerians
is the only human in this series to ever
lay eyes upon them
most of the ship consisted of thin tubes
and tiny cubbies some the size of
matchboxes others as large as a drawer
and a dresser
each cubby contained numerous tiny
apparatuses or devices glowing with an
eerie light each about the size of a
grain of rice
some of the grains squirmed and writhed
on the floor
they are bugs
the description of the tricelerians as
bug-like creatures seems to imply that
the tricelerin insult of bugs towards
humans at the end of the first book was
merely a tricelerian projection of their
own inadequacy in this particular aspect
a key fact about the tricelerians that
redemption of time also goes into is
that the trisolarins apparently are not
independently intelligent they must
depend on group data tricelerian
cognition was very different from
individual based human cognition because
trisolarent enjoyed a direct
correspondence between thought and
expression their communication was
highly efficient
they thus evolved a collective
intelligence that was the foundation of
the living formation computer innovation
although each individual tricelerian
could to some degree think independently
they primarily relied on exchanging
information with each other to build up
a large collective data bank that was
their primary source of intelligence
nothing about the description of the
tricelerians and redemption of time is
out of line with anything that shenlure
writes about the tricelerins in the
original three novels
i in fact remember getting the distinct
thought while reading them that the
tricelerins might be tiny creatures
typically large animals wouldn't have
the ability to dehydrate themselves and
rehydrate later on earth that is a trait
that we see in very small creatures like
water bears for instance
the tricelerians were humanity's
greatest oppressors but perhaps without
them humanity would have never been
alerted to the darker truths about the
nature of the universe and our existence
in it
so have you read the three-body problem
series did you enjoy it tell me what you
thought about it also recommend any
other science fiction books that you'd
like to see me cover on this channel
thanks for watching guys make sure you
like and subscribe for more videos like
this one peace out
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the lie behind the star is launching
february 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]
[Music]
you